when you have a look at this these quick
questions these answers that we put down
here right we have a whole bunch of
words a lot of language and terminology
that we use to describe what's going on
for instance rather than saying or you
know that number that's the small one
that you write up above we actually have
not one not two but three different
names that we call that number by and we
sort of used it I've got some written on
the board we used it in language can
someone give me one example of a name
that gets given to this number of the
top so here did you I start us off just
one exponent okay so Andy's gone
straight for the most fancy of the names
okay it's the it's the name that you use
when you want to sound spot like oh
what's the exponent of that do you give
me a second one index and you can see
we've already written that on the board
and then the last one yeah
power fantastic so these new words all
refer to the same thing right when we
say five to the power of four all we
might say the index is four or the
exponent is 4 okay that's that thing at
the top by contrast this thing down the
bottom we generally only give it one
name it's down the bottom so what
because somebody's not suggesting
something yet you go ahead it's the base
thank you drop the base all right now
the base down the bottom and the index
the exponent and the power so we know
what index notation is we could
translate 5 times 5 times 5 times 5 we
can translate into index notation but
index laws are not about translation
they're actually about transaction can
we do things together when we've got
lots of things with indices ok so I'm
going to give you a few examples of what
this actually looks like and we'll see
if we can draw some conclusions out of
them ok so the first little subheading I
want you to put underneath the heading
index laws is multiplication now the
reason why we're starting with
multiplication under this heading is
because index laws or index notation
rather it's about multiplication it's
like a shorthand an abbreviation of
multiplying lots of things so if we
think about multiplying things together
which are in this form some of our some
of the knowledge that we have so here's
our first example
we'll make is a lot easier
okay so let's think about this if I were
to multiply 7 squared and 7 to the power
of 4 some of you might immediately be
able to tell me the answer which is
great but I don't you know hold that
thought for a second because I want to
know not just what the answer is but why
the answer is what it is to do that
let's unpack what does 7 squared what's
in an abbreviation of yeah you know
you've been very quiet so far could you
give us a suggestion 7 squared how could
you expand that ok so the answer if we
evaluated it be 49 right where you got
49 was 7 times 7 right yep yep so we've
got 7 times 7 that's what seven squared
means and of course if you actually
calculate that before you know it seven
squared gives you that 7 to the power of
4 of course is 7 times 7 times 7 times 7
one last time ok now sorry that's a
really bad bracket there we go
how many sevens do I have written on the
board there I have six over here on the
right hand side you can literally count
them 1 2 3 4 5 6 so therefore my
abbreviation for this rather than
writing all those many times is 7 to the
power of 6 now this is a very long way
of going about it because I had to sort
of expand it out we don't have to do
this if you write the left hand side
again you can notice there is a really
straightforward nice connection between
the left hand side and the right there
is what are you seeing yeah fantastic if
you all didn't hear that right these
powers over here 2 & 4 if you just add
them together you get the 6 right so
what you've got over here is really 7 to
the power of 2 plus 4 this makes us any
questions
yep so far so good ok now I want you to
think about what happens if example two
what if you've got not just two numbers
with the same base what if you have like
a whole bunch of them for example let's
have a look at something like this let's
go up to the 5 okay now again just
because we're trying to establish where
this comes from I don't want you just to
be able to bless you I don't want what
do any bless you but I don't want to
just have a like there's a property
there's a law
just gonna do it like a machine I want
you to know why it's going on so it's
gonna let's expand this first okay so
three squared what is three squared mean
it's three times three let's write that
down so I've done this guy then I'm
multiplying by three in the middle and
then three to the power of five is three
times three times three times three
times three
can't you see how the reason I'm doing
this to you is so that you sense how
wonderful index notation is just such a
time saver but I'm gonna write them all
down five times okay now just like
before with the sevens how many threes
can you see written on the right hand
side Tim how many do you count eight one
two three four five six seven eight
now this answer interests me because
when I look at the left-hand side and
like I just add these powers right I got
six when I had these powers it looks
like I get seven what's what's going on
there right so see this guy here right
we wouldn't like normally say oh it's an
index notation right there's no index
there but there is one it's just kind of
hiding right it's an index I'd love you
to write this on the second line it's an
index of one that there's a single three
there that's why there it is
right so in fact I am doing just like I
did before I'm taking all of these
indices here and I'm adding them
together two plus one plus five sure
enough it does equal eight